[Applause]
thank you Ian for that introduction it's
always an honor to speak at Queens so
I'd like to thank the president and vice
president for the invitation today
this is a special place a first class
University for research technology and
Innovation business and health an
institution that's always been rooted in
its communities here in Belfast and in
Northern Ireland
but which also enjoys a huge Global
reach a reach Nevermore on display than
the you know in the appointment of your
chancellors and we can see them on the
wall here today
after all
who better to carry the message of Peace
this city embodies around the world
than Hillary Clinton
I've been here to Queens many times in
fact I remember the last time clearly
because I was halfway through my speech
when the United Kingdom announced a vote
on article 50.
what a relief it is that that's all now
behind us
now that day when I last came I came
here to reflect on the success of the
Police Service of Northern Ireland
and my role was the human rights advisor
to the policing board which oversees it
I'm immensely proud of the work of the
board
of that whole period in my life
it's given me a lasting love of Northern
Ireland
friendships that have endured including
people in this room here today
memories I'll always cherish and you
know after we were married my wife and I
took our first holiday here because I
wanted to show her Northern Ireland the
people and the communities that I'd met
I was in love with this island and that
love has stayed with me
it's also taught me so much about
politics about change about the power of
Hope
and this year is a moment of reflection
for Northern Ireland and
speaking for myself standing here in
2023 it's hard to describe just how
different it feels to the Northern
Ireland of 20 years ago when I first
came to take up my role here
how raw the emotions were back then in a
country still coming to terms with its
hard one but fragile peace
I wanted a chance to serve because it
felt like a huge moment
a chance to turn the pages on decades if
not centuries of pain
and I wanted to make a contribution
help to create a lasting Institution
one that could reach out to all
communities
hold the police to account and in doing
so help pursue the peace for future
Generations
I think we did that
accountability transparency human rights
the framework we put in place was
critical for both communities
to have a degree of faith that the
police service of Northern Ireland was
new was different was worth those first
risky steps
we were tested of course
every day as Tony Blair said at the time
every Advance made in the name of the
Belfast Good Friday agreement has to be
ground out
but over time policing in Northern
Ireland did change
the Pierce and I did become an
institution which enjoys cross-community
support
Catholics did sign up to serve not
enough in Northern Ireland you can
always point to the work that still
needs to be done
but if you'd said to us then
in 2003
that in 20 years we'd have the Pearson
eye we have today
that one day a shin Fein leader would
stand shoulder to shoulder with unionist
leaders in a campaign to help Recruit
new officers
yes
that would have felt like an achievement
worth celebrating
and there are people here today who
deserve huge credit for helping to make
that happen
this year should be a year we celebrate
achievements like that
all the achievements big and small of
the Good Friday agreement
25 years of relative peace prosperity
and a better Northern Ireland
it's a proud moment for me reflecting on
the small role I played in that
and it's obviously a huge moment for my
party
The Good Friday agreement is the
greatest achievement of the labor party
in my lifetime without question
but of course
the real achievement
the real Pride
belongs to the people and the
communities here in Northern Ireland
it's your bravery
your determination
your courage resilience and yes your
willingness to sacrifice to compromise
to stand despite everything in the shoes
of other communities
and above all to keep doing so
when there were bumps in the road
provocation
outbreaks of violence
that's what won this piece
it's why I fell in love with this place
I'd never seen anything like that spirit
that hope
I talk a lot about Hope at the moment
about how hard it is for people to get
through the challenges we face without
the real possibility of something better
how has we lurched from crisis to crisis
we're losing our faith that the future
will be better for our children
some communities in the United Kingdom
might once have taken that for granted
but not here
because what I saw in Northern Ireland
20 years ago were people and communities
experiencing that hope
for the first time
it's what powered The Good Friday
agreement drove the communities of this
country on towards the history they made
and we've got to get it back
because I get the sense
with the protocol
with the political situation at storm on
not to mention the other problems we see
here the NHS the cost of living and
economy on its knees
that the thought of April being a true
celebration
feels a little on ice
I understand that
anniversaries are hard in Northern
Ireland
looking back is hard
even when we do so with pride as we
should in April
it's tough
the past is a painful place for so many
people
so many communities
people have suffered a lot
and with that comes a fear
fear that if we stop trying to move
forward if things grind to a halt
then we could yet go backwards
it's why here more than anywhere you
always need that hope of a better future
that's the spirit of 1998. that's what
the Good Friday agreement asked of
people
it wasn't to forgive or forget
they were demands that could never be
made
it was only to look forward
to commit to a journey walk step by step
each stride difficult each stride
precious towards a better future
together
the anniversary this year should be a
true celebration people deserve that
history was made here hard one
but to respect that history people also
deserve action on the issues which
currently hold Northern Ireland back
for politics to do its job and give
people a chance to look forward with
hope
now there is a small window of
opportunity before April
we've got to use the anniversary to fix
Minds
get the country and its political
process moving forward again
deliver for the people of Northern
Ireland
I see two key priorities for this
they're both urgent both need to happen
now
and so of course
they rely on a change of direction from
the prime minister
but
in each priority I also want to show the
values I will bring to Northern Ireland
if I have the honor to serve as prime
minister
first
the British government must normalize
and strengthen relationships with Dublin
the two shock held out an olive branch
in recent weeks we must take it
but honestly relations should never have
been this strained
brexit was a rupture in the UK's
diplomatic stance a call to change in
every era of our society which had to be
recognized
I've been very clear about this my
government will make it work will take
on the mantle of that vote we'll turn
its slogans into practical Solutions
yet throughout the last seven years
nothing has been more self-defeating
than the determination of some
conservative ministers to see our
friends in Dublin as adversaries on
brexit
that has damaged the political process
here in Northern Ireland no question
and it's certainly not the spirit of
1998.
we should never lose sight of what binds
us together on these islands
our shared commitment to peace here
above all other considerations
so I encourage the Prime Minister as the
t-shockers said
to recognize past mistakes
it will help him with the second
priority
the obvious one
the protocol
look there's no point varnishing the
truth
to get beyond the current stalemate we
have to make the protocol work
nobody wants to see unnecessary checks
on Goods moving between Great Britain
and Northern Ireland
we just need to find a solution
and I want to commend the recent
agreement on trade data sharing
commend the EU commend the government
if they are finally serious about a deal
there will be no sniping from us
I can promise you that
I go back to the Good Friday agreement
The Pride we feel in the labor party
towards it has no bounds
but we know
the political effort didn't just come
from us from Tony Blair and momolam
it didn't come just from Bertier Hearn
and Mary mcalees from the unwavering
support from the U.S Bill Clinton George
Mitchell
or the tenacity and Brilliance of John
Hume and David Trimble it was also built
on the work of John Major
and Albert Reynolds
and afterwards by Lord Patton
whose commission led to the Pearson eye
and the policing board in the first
place
my point is this
the spirit of 1998 on both islands is
not one of tribal politics
this is the process which brought in
Paisley and Martin McGuinness together
and they made it work there can be no
clearer example than that
so I say to the prime minister
if there is a deal to do in coming weeks
do it
whatever political cover you need
whatever mechanisms in Westminster you
require
if it delivers for our national interest
and the people of Northern Ireland
we will support you
the time for action on the protocol is
now
the time to stand up to the ERG is now
the time to put Northern Ireland above a
brexit purity cult which could never be
satisfied is now
[Applause]
we can find ways to remove the majority
of checks a bespoke SPS agreement a
monitoring system that eradicates checks
on Goods that will only ever be sold in
Northern Ireland
opportunity for these reforms is there
and they would deliver for communities
and businesses across these islands
Northern Ireland can be prosperous under
the protocol
but it requires leadership from you
prime minister
and look
I enjoyed my dialogue with the dup and
unionist parties yesterday
so I want to reach out on this
speak to all unionist communities
there are legitimate problems with the
protocol
and these must be recognized in any
negotiations
and as for the process that got us here
to this point I think your anger about
that is more than Justified
I said this yesterday
I will say it here and I want every
community in Northern Ireland to hear it
the labor party will always be a good
faith guarantor of the Constitution and
the principle of consent
that commitment is written into the
agreement we want to celebrate in April
it stands above politics it should stand
above brexit negotiations as well
I think people know that we would have
done things differently
and that we will stand by those values
when in government
but I also want to say this
in the coming weeks
it's possible there will be siren voices
in Westminster that say again
there's another path
a path that doesn't require compromise
on the protocol
in fact it's possible those siren voices
will include may even be led by
the very people who created the protocol
that were Cavalier with the
Constitutional settlement of this United
Kingdom that came to this island and
acted to be blunt in bad faith
you can listen to those voices of course
it's not for me to determine the
interests of any Community here
but I would counsel that the example to
follow
is not theirs
but the spirit of negotiation of
conciliation of Courage
that in the end is always the force
which moves Northern Ireland forward
towards the future
that's what I want to do in April look
forward
Northern Ireland is personal to me
The Good Friday agreement is personal to
me
the drift the lack of momentum the
elevation of ideological politics above
the Constitutional settlement that would
never happen
with my labor government
would never happen with any labor
government
it's not how we approach Politics on
this island
it's not how my predecessors helped
broker peace
my ambition as prime minister would be
to give the people of Northern Ireland
the hope I saw here in 2003.
the sort of hope you can build your
future around
that aspirations are made of
and which can as we've seen for 25 years
bring communities together
ordinary hope
and ordinary politics
that's what the people of Northern
Ireland deserve
and we will govern by their example
when things get tough we will persevere
embrace the spirit of 1998.
keep our eyes fixed firmly on the future
a future of peace and prosperity
partnership between Britain and Ireland
and a politics which delivers for every
community in Northern Ireland thank you
very much
thank you very much we've got some
questions I'm going to take some media
questions first and then some from uh
everybody else can I start please with
Gareth Gordon BBC Northern Ireland
tariff morning sir here
um first of all you talk about the need
for the government to stand up to the
ERG How likely is that when the ERG
seemed to be essentially running the nio
number one and number two at the nio are
former chairs of the ERG and perhaps you
saw a little bit of that this week and
their interactions over Mary Lee
McDonald involvement and protocol talks
and just secondly isn't it likely that
the EU and the UK will do a deal in the
next few months over the protocol and it
will be presented to the parties
including the dup on a ticket or leave
it basis well look um Gareth I do think
genuinely that there's a window of
opportunity to make progress here there
have been important progress in the last
few days
and I want that to be progress and
that's what I mean by not being tribal
about this we take no comfort in a
failure by the government to make
progress so I want the government and
the EU to make progress
and if they do so we will support them
and that is because in the past the EOG
have blocked progress and so I'm being
very clear with the prime minister
um in saying that if we do get a deal
and it's in the National interest in the
interests of Northern Ireland
then we will support it notwithstanding
the ERG and whatever position they take
and that's why I say it now it's because
uh I think progress here
is above politics it has that's what
that's was the spirit of 1998 uh it has
to be the spirit now 25 years later as
we try to make progress thank you Vicky
from UTV
at good morning to Care on a similar
vein you've spoken this morning about
giving the government political cover
for a deal on the protocol does that
support uh is it conditional on support
from all the parties in Northern Ireland
again you've spoken about reaching out
to unionists this morning the dup of
course are essential to getting Stormont
back up and running so is your support
to the government uh is it
are you giving kind of some kind of
commitment that you will listen to the
dup as well uh thank you Vicki
um of course we'll listen to the dup as
well I've had very extensive
um and very productive discussions with
all the political parties yesterday
including the dup
um and we'll continue to engage with all
political parties on this I do think
reflecting on those discussions that
there is a shared sense that we can make
progress just at the moment of course
there will be challenges of course there
will be difficulties
um and my message in my speech to the
dup and others
was a reflection of the discussion we've
been having in recent days and weeks so
I do offer that support to the
government knowing what the challenges
are and it's why I say in particular
uh or that my view is that the siren
voices and there will be siren voices as
soon as there's any progress there will
be siren voices saying don't compromise
don't go forward
they may be led by as I say the very
people who negotiated the protocol in
the first place
and I'm
inviting I'm suggesting that those siren
voices should be left to one side and we
move together forward I will engage with
the dup and others as we do that because
I do think there is this window of
opportunity to go forward thank you
Vicky Jude from the ft
yes thank you secure
um sorry I'll sit down because I've got
too many bits right
um you mentioned in in your government
that you wouldn't allow drift to
continue but there's a very real
possibility isn't there that there might
be a deal that's acceptable to London
and Brussels that doesn't fly with the
dup that doesn't get storm and back up
and running
say this drift continues it's happened
before in Northern Ireland and you come
in as prime minister what do you do to
end that how do you break that deadlock
well I would act in government as I
acted yesterday and as I've acted in the
last three years which is to engage
meaningfully with all the political
parties here in Northern Ireland
and that's what we did yesterday it's
what we've done previously it's what
we'll continue to do we would also as I
said out in the speech a moment ago
reset the relations with Ireland they
should never have been allowed to get
into the state they've been in for the
past few years so we would reset that
relationship that is a priority for me
for an incoming labor government but
also to settle a protocol and move
forward engaging with all the political
parties here in Northern Ireland of
course that's difficult but we have to
make progress we have to take same
mindset as we had in 1998 Elevate this
above politics
and ensure that the siren voices that
always hold Northern Ireland back are
silenced and we can move forward thank
you Jude David from PA I think
good morning good morning sir here as
you said a deal May materialize in the
coming weeks um a deal may not
materialize in the coming weeks we also
may get a deal that um has been
referenced the dep may not sign up to
and this could continue to drift without
Stormwind and place for the coming years
um a Libra government if you do come
into par there are those that um
potentially suggest the solution to this
ultimately and a way to address unionist
concerns about their place within the
union being undermined is a UK wide
approach to the EU on a closer
relationship with you with the EU on a
UK wide basis you know potentially in an
overarching SPS deal or some form of
Customs Union would a labor government
be prepared to countenance that if it
ultimately delivered
um the dep by our return to power
sharing it stormed well
um I've made clear that
um what an incoming labor government
would do was would be to make brexit
work all we've got at the moment
um is
um a deal and not a very good deal for
the whole United Kingdom we need to
improve on that we need closer trading
relations we need better joint work on
research and Technology we need stronger
security Arrangements all of that I
think is possible if we're able to
restore good faith and integrity into
the negotiations so we would move
forward to make brexit work for the
whole of the United Kingdom and that
would I think inevitably reduce some of
the tensions in relation to the
situation in Northern Ireland but having
said that what I don't the message I do
not want to give today is that somehow
we can wait for hopefully a future labor
government of course I want that to
happen
what I want is progress now I think what
businesses and communities here in
Northern Ireland want is progress now
and that's why
um rather than simply say wait for an
incoming labor government to take a
different grown-up approach negotiating
better faith for a better future which
we will do I want progress on the
protocol now which is why I'm prepared
to save the Prime Minister if you do
manage to get a deal which is in the
National interest in the interest of
Northern Ireland then we will support it
and therefore you don't need to worry
about those siren voices in the ERG who
undoubtedly will be the voices holding
Northern Ireland back
thank you David and Amanda
thank you Amanda
has to oversee the process of a border
pool on the island of Ireland that may
take place at some point in in the
coming years and of course the British
and Irish governments have a particular
role as cool guarantors of the Good
Friday agreement in Northern Ireland and
have to reflect Union Assan nationalist
positions but you have spoken before
about your unionism so I'm just
wondering um why are you a unionist and
what is your pitch to the people of
Northern Ireland about why their best
place to maintain the union well look at
that Amanda I think
um we're getting way ahead of ourselves
uh in relation to uh that question that
the the focus and the priority at the
moment is obviously on the protocol we
were in hours and hours of discussion
with the political parties here in
Northern Ireland yesterday and the
protocol was you know the single focus
of those discussions of course there are
other issues that are always to be
discussed in any discussions in Northern
Ireland but that is the absolute focus
and that is what we will bring to bear
along with the task of making brexit
work which will be Central to the tasks
and priority of an incoming labor
government thank you Amanda can I now
invite Pro Vice Chancellor Professor
Nola Hewitt dundasup to the stage please
uh said I can take some questions from
the audience
secure thank you so much for the very
informative and broad-reaching speech
that you've just given and very
passionate speech full of Hope and hope
would use so many times within that and
obviously we've talked a lot about
brexit we've talked a lot about the
protocol we would like to open it up to
the audience because I'm sure there are
also other issues that people are
exercised about yes if you could just
wait for the roving mic to reach you
that would be great
thank you good morning sir here my name
is Kalina McCartney and as we approached
25 years since the Good Friday agreement
Labor's greatest achievement in Northern
Ireland I wanted to ask when you become
Prime Minister and I'm saying when not
if because I'm hopeful and excited what
will your priorities be for Northern
Ireland thank you
uh thank you very much I you know
we don't know when the next election is
going to be other than that we'll have
to be in the next two years we hope that
we can bring about change I think
um increasingly there's a sense of
frustration that we haven't got the hope
and change that we need what I will
bring to Northern Ireland are the values
that underpin the Good Friday agreement
and that as I say was the single biggest
achievement of the last Labor government
and we're proud of it and we understand
those values which are hardwired into
that agreement and hardwired frankly
into the labor party I bring
um I hope an understanding of Northern
Ireland having had the privilege of
working here for five years and
understanding what that hope what those
values meant in practice to so many
people and communities here that's why I
love this place but also a sense of a
positive
future for the United Kingdom whatever
the challenges are that are out there I
see each of those challenges as a huge
opportunity and this morning inevitably
we talk about the protocol but there are
many other issues that energy business
what we do about our Health Service what
we do about the economy all of which are
challenges all of which I think we
should run to and grab as opportunities
for the future so an incoming labor
party will be a government of Hope and
of change so that we can get our future
back thank you
okay um just over here so care welcome
back to Queens I'm Karen McAvoy I'm a
law professor here in the university and
my question is about dealing with the
legacy of the conflict
um as you know
um there is a piece of legislation going
back before the Lord's Northern Ireland
Troublesome reconciliation bill
um which your party has rightly opposed
as have all of the opposition parties in
Westminster that bill is opposed by all
of the political parties here rare
consensus politically here as opposed by
victims organizations across the
community it's opposed by the Irish
government it's opposed by everyone on
this island basically in terms of the
major stakeholders more or less so I
don't think they labor I don't think a
labor government would ever have
introduced such a piece of legislation
but it's a direct question if you are
elected prime minister will you repeat
that bill
uh yes
um but let me
let me just elaborate a little because
obviously having had the privilege of
working here for five years with the
policing board Police Service Northern
Ireland
um I know firsthand and having spoken to
many many victims and victims
Representatives I know just how deep
this goes for very obvious reasons I
think the legislation is wrong in
principle
but worse than that or alongside that
no government in Westminster in my view
should ever introduce legislation which
has no support from any of the political
parties in Northern Ireland and no
support from the victims who are at the
heart of this and I think that previous
governments labor and conservatives
would have understood that and it shows
you how far this conservative government
in recent years has moved from a genuine
understanding of the principles and
values of the Good Friday agreement that
they would even countenance introducing
legislation with zero political support
here and zero support from the victims
we wouldn't do it and we'd repeal it if
it's on the statute but when we come
into power thank you
okay there's a further question here hi
I'm Chloe Ferguson I'm the president at
the national students union here in
Northern Ireland we're obviously here in
Queens today a place of learning and I
suppose to kind of ground this
conversation in that as well in the
future of labor party and how would you
prioritize and commit to the role of
fully funded education to create further
access for students and apprentices and
hire and further education and a
potential future labor government but
also Northern Ireland and on that how
would you particularly deliver for
students and apprentices in this cost
living crisis because we are seeing a
real lack of that from the government
currently thank you well look thank you
very much for raising that and
um I think that students at the moment
having a particularly hard time because
of the opportunities that are being
denied and because of the funding and
because of the cost of living crisis
which hits students very very hard I do
think we could move forward on this I
want students here in Northern Ireland
across the United Kingdom have the
opportunity to study here if they want
to but to study elsewhere if they want
to do that as well it's a very important
opportunity I want students from across
the world to be welcome to study here in
the United Kingdom I want the best
students to come here because I want
them to study here and I know that if
they do study here in Northern Ireland
or the United Kingdom all the evidence
shows that that builds a relationship
which is beneficial for everyone going
forward I think it's not just students
though you mentioned apprentices as well
too often I think
we sort of put students and University
here and apprentices over there and they
should not be in two separate places
they should be on an equal footing
equally regarded equally respected and
so we want an uplifting huge
apprenticeship scheme going forward to
allow young people to come out of school
and take either path and feel the pride
and dignity that goes with either going
to University of course or going on to
apprenticeship of course and
um in a way this is personal to me I was
lucky enough to be the first person in
my family to go to university
um my dad by contrast was a was a tool
maker a skilled engineer working in a
factory and I couldn't help feeling for
many years that
um deep down there was this sense that
University was good but skilled
engineering not so much completely wrong
and we need to turn that around thank
you very much for that question
okay there really is no shortage of
hands in this Hall going up this morning
and I think we have another one here and
the robin mic has already been passed to
you
hi I'm Karen portray one of the
sabbatical officers here at Queen
students union um I want to ask in
recent years more and more young people
have been emigrating from Northern
Ireland uh young people who are born
around or even after the Good Friday
agreement was formed
um because we're seeing an assembly that
time and time again cannot function and
in the name of the protocol dances
around some of the key issues we have a
cost of living crisis that's worsening
by the day there's the continued refusal
to practically Implement abortion
Services by decriminalization and the
inability to tackle gendered violence as
women in Northern Ireland are unable to
feel safe in any real aspect of their
lives I want to ask with the upcoming
25th anniversary of the Good Friday
agreement how are young people on normal
Island expected to celebrate this
anniversary when time and time again
we've been left with no real support
through crisis after crisis in recent
years but could I empathize
and challenge
empathize because there is a real cost
of living crisis the institutions aren't
up the frustration
um is there and whichever way you look
it looks as though there were challenges
everywhere sometimes it feels impossible
to to rise to those challenges
but what I would say is just think back
to 25 years ago
think about the enormity of the issues
that were being dealt with enormous
issues going into 1998 and the courage
and commitment it took
to move forward despite those challenges
and my challenge back to you on the
protocol in many resenses is if it was
possible 25 years ago to bring people
together around the Belfast Good Friday
agreement notwithstanding the enormity
of those challenges it must surely be
possible now to make progress on the
protocol on the future of Northern
Ireland and the future of the United
Kingdom but we need to do that together
and young people are hugely important in
this because it's your future that we're
determining through the actions that we
take today so thank you for raising that
I can feel the frustration that you have
with the challenges that are there not
of your making but I do say
um you know I do think we can face up to
these challenges they are really
important challenges but compared with
what was being addressed when the Good
Friday agreement was agreed they are
lesser challenges in my view and can be
overcome thank you okay thank you very
much and there are very many more
questions but unfortunately secure has
an incredibly busy agenda and we're
going to have to draw a line under it so
here thank you for your time thank you
for your depth of understanding of the
issues that are here the very complex
issues but what has most definitely come
across is your passion to find a way
forward and commitment to a personal
commitment to doing that and achieving
that so we very much appreciate you
coming and spending time with us here
this morning thank you so much and thank
you all for coming this morning I really
really appreciate it thank you